hi this is fresh to Locker in this video
I'm going to show you a trick how you
can quickly square numbers in your head
if they begin with a string of threes
and end and a4 or begin with the string
of sixes and end and a7 we'll illustrate
the procedure with an example of 34 the
first step is just to write down the
number six the second step is to count
how many times the number three appears
and in 34 it appears exactly one time so
we write the number five exactly one
time and then we write the number one an
extra time
so 34 squared is one one five six
in another example we have 334 squared
we start by writing the number six and
then we count how many times the digit 3
appears on the number in 334 that's two
times so we write the same number of
fives and we write an extra number of
ones so 3 34 squared will be one one one
five five six and this turns out to be a
pattern anytime you have a number that
starts with a string of threes you can
count the number of times the 3 appears
and that's how many times you'll have
five in the answer and there will be one
more appearance of the digit one and in
the unit's place it's the number six
there is a similar procedure for numbers
that start with six a string of sixes
and ended 7 4 67 squared we write out
the number 9 and then we count how many
times the digit six appears in this case
it's 1 and that's how many times we
write the number 8 and then we write the
number 4 one extra time so 67 squared is
four four eight nine in another example
six six seven squared we write down the
digit 9 and then we count that there are
two appearances of the digit six so we
write the number eight that many times
and the number four we're going to write
one extra time so this is another neat
pattern that whenever you have a number
starting with a string of sixes and
ending in two seven you count how many
times the number six appears and that's
how many times the number eight will
appear in the answer and the number four
will appear one more time I hope you
like this video please subscribe to my
channel you can also catch me on my blog
mind your decisions or on twitter at
pressure Walker